[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue sur le plateau
de territoire de ce plateau des
territoires le plateau de face aux
territoires sur tv5 monde avec nos
partenaires de la presse quotidienne
régionale ouest france.fr nicematin.com
par contre france antilles point fr
lamontagne.fr et 20minutes.fr
retransmettre en direct cette émission
également est en repli et bien sûr sur
leur site réciproque mon invité
aujourd'hui c'est thierry baudet bonjour
bonjour le président du conseil
économique social et environnemental
on ne l'oublient pas ça a été rajouté je
crois sous la présidence de nicolas
sarkozy cette appellation
environnemental on en parlera avec vous
on l'appelle le cee et vous êtes la
troisième assemblée de la république on
vous connaît mal on va tenter pendant 40
minutes en direct de vous connaître
mieux une question à vous poser tout de
suite sur cette guerre en ukraine j'ai
lu que douze conseils économiques et
sociaux européens ont fait une
déclaration commune par rapport à cette
guerre qu'en est il oui j'ai pris une
initiative parce que j'ai considéré que
toutes les voix comptaient est tous les
symboles compter et j'ai souhaité que
les sociétés civiles européennes
témoigne leur solidarité au peuple
ukrainien et d'ailleurs mon homologue
ukrainien est intervenue depuis kiev
devant une dans une séance du du cee
c'était très émouvant il nous a dit
combien c'était important et je veux
dire que des organisations du cee sont
très engagés la croix rouge française on
le sait et puis reporters sans
frontières qui fait en sorte que les
journalistes puissent exercer leur
métier pour nous continuer à nous
informer thierry bonnet vous êtes donc
président de cette troisième assemblée
du pays est ce que vous avez utilisé
vous des cabinets conseils type
mackenzie c'est arrivé notamment sur les
questions démocratiques
quand on pense aux saisons on pense
beaucoup à la convention citoyenne
climat on s'est fait après payer autant
heureux de cet accompagnement oui on a
eu besoin de se faire accompagner
maintenant moi c'est ce site est une
première les charges est organisée une
démarche où je suis en train de
d'internaliser un certain nombre de
compétences pour que la participation
citoyenne compte participe du
fonctionnement j'allais dire ordinaire
du cee et j'intègre déclarant ce que ça
coûte cher la démocratie est là
là elle a un coût au cec transparent on
peut consacrer jusqu'à 10 % de notre
budget c'est à dire 4 millions d'euros
aux démarches de participation citoyenne
un budget de 40 millions d'euros 2,4 me
c'est ça hein 40 millions d'euros pour
le cee et jusqu'à 4 millions d'euros
pour la participation citoyenne et dans
ses quatre millions d'euros on peut
faire appel un certain nombre de
concours externe qui nous sont utiles
thierry baudet président du conseil
économique social et environnemental est
notre invité ce matin pendant 40 minutes
en direct dans face aux territoires sur
ce plateau dans un instant
françois-xavier le franc le rédacteur en
chef de ouest france
[Musique]
lefranc vous n de rédacteur en chef du
quotidien français le plus francophone
au monde merci d'être avec nous ce matin
et donc on va parler de ce cce de son
fonctionnement de ses activités bonjour
monsieur baudet alors le conseil
économique social et environnemental
c'est une institution qui est importante
mais que les français on peut lire
connaissent très peu alors ma première
question les simples à quoi ça sert 7
sept cette institution qui est qui qui
comportements qui ne sont pas élus qui
sont désignés on y reviendra mais
d'abord à quoi elle sert voileux le c2c
de ses conseils
ça veut dire que c'est une
assemblée de mes prédécesseurs disait
qui a le premier mot sur un certain
nombre de sujets qui font l'avenir du
pays on essaie de formuler des
propositions pour aider à l'élaboration
des politiques publiques et vous avez
dit qu'on allait revenir sur la
composition comme nous sommes très
divers et comme nous regardons le monde
depuis des endroits différents on essaie
de formuler des points de vue qui puisse
permette que les politiques publiques
puissent trouver à s'exercer on
travaille en quelque sorte sur des voies
de passage on propose des voies de
passage sur des sujets complexes en
veillant toujours à l'acceptabilité par
les populations et les politiques que
vous êtes la troisième assemblée les
deux autres elles sont composées de
membres élus les membres du cae ne sont
pas élus alors comment sont-ils désigné
qui sont-ils qui représente il est est
ce qu'ils sont vraiment représentatifs
de la société française
175 membres des entrepreneurs des
agriculteurs des artisans des
syndicalistes des responsables
associatifs des ong qui agissent dans le
champ économique dans le champ de la
cohésion sociale territoriale dans le
champ de l'environnement 175 mans en
moyenne d'âge 57 ans il ya des jeunes
aussi il ya des jeunes les
organisations et mouvements de jeunesse
sont représentées sont représentés au
cee et ils représentent 82 organisations
82 organisations qui font ce que
j'appelle la société agissante celles et
ceux qui dans le pays eux au quotidien
agi sans résignation comment ça se passe
on présente sa candidature au 16e ou
est-ce qu'on est appelé à ce qu'on ait
décidé que françois-xavier le franc
pourrait par exemple devenir membre du
cae alors si elles sont les critères
c'est le premier ministre qui désigne
les organisations présentes océans une
chance elle en est pour chaque
organisation et pour chaque organisation
qui indique combien de personnes
pourront la représenter on a quatre
piliers les les employeurs
les syndicalistes encore une fois les
ong les associations et puis les
environnementalistes oui puisque la
partie environnement on y reviendra plus
tard c'est quelque chose
videmment d'importants alors comment ça
se passe vous faites des rapports
comment est ce que vous vous proposez
vos idées comment est-ce que vous
conseiller comment ça se passe et les
rapports qui vous sont commandés
on peut à la fois être saisie par le
gouvernement ou le parlement le
gouvernement le plus souvent le
parlement moins fréquemment pour être
très concret on a été saisie tout
récemment
on nous a invités à faire des
propositions pour développer un service
public de la petite enfance on nous
amener à réfléchir à l'acceptation
sociale des infrastructures de la
transition énergétique
on a travaillé sur la question
démocratique et sur l'abstention des
jeunes ça c'était des des commandes du
premier ministre donc on travaille on a
des cycles d'audition on associe parfois
des citoyens aux travaux et on formule
des propositions au gouvernement et on
peut aussi s'autosaisir ce que nous
appelons de saisine d'initiatives sans
175 membres qui sont originaires de
toutes les régions françaises on peut le
dire les territoires ultramarins qui
nous écoutent sont évidemment eux aussi
représentée au sein du conseil
économique social et environnemental
oui si c'est une spécificité six membres
pour représenter les territoires du tram
à ramer comme vous l'avez dit les
organisations qui sont présentes sur
l'ensemble du territoire national
désigne des membres venant de tout tout
notre pays a la droit à la fois dans
l'hexagone et dans les territoires on
peut dire que c'est une assemblée qui
sent bien la société française qui la
connaît bien qui la représente bien
qu'ils représentent un peu sa diversité
quel regard portez vous sur l'état de
notre démocratie nous sommes à quelques
jours d'un rendez vous électoral majeur
évidemment on va élire la personnalité
qui occupera la présidence de la
république on a l'impression de notre
démocratie est pour le moins fatigué que
les le système politique ce qu'on
appelle le système qui inclut les
politiques les médias et tout le reste
s'éloigne des citoyens c'est a ressenti
en tout cas de la part des citoyens quel
regard portez-vous sur la société
française à quelques jours de ce
rendez-vous qui est important
naturellement au cse nous sommes
préoccupés à la fois par la défiance qui
s'expriment envers les institutions est
d'abord envers les institutions
politiques et puis la montée de
l'abstention je rappelle que lors des
dernières départemental et régional 87 %
des 18-24 ans ne sont pas allés voter
alors cette abstention
on l'analyse souvent comme une forme de
colère je pense qu elle marque aussi une
forme de fatalisme à savoir à quoi bon
aller voter si finalement mon vote ne va
pas changer ne va pas changer ma vie
quotidienne ce dont je suis convaincu
c'est qu'il ne faut pas en conclure que
les français sont apathiques bien au
contraire il ya une envie de
participation plus forte que jamais sur
les sujets qui nous concernent et et ma
conviction c'est que aujourd'hui la
démocratie on ne peut pas simplement là
la limite et au dimanche d'élection est
une des questions majeures pour leur
histoire l'ensemble des candidats c'est
comme normand c'est ce qu'on peu comment
fait-on démocratie qu'il faut changer
les institutions est ce que ce sont nos
institutions qui qui sont fatigués
qu'est ce qu'il faut faire moi je crois
qu'il faut
associer davantage
les citoyens les
dispositifs
participation citoyenne sont utiles ils
ont fait leurs preuves depuis très
longtemps au plan local il ya longtemps
que les maires ils font référence il
faut
systématiser un peu ces dispositifs au
plan national il faut associer les
citoyens sujets qui les concernent
le renforcement de la démocratie
participative avec les citoyens en amont
de celles et ceux qui ont le dernier mot
est un bon facteur pour renforcer la
démocratie représentative c'est thierry
baudet le président du conseil
économique social et environnemental
qu'est notre invité ce matin d'en face
aux territoires fauniques et dessinateur
collaborateur dewatine roman comme vous
est normand comme vous très important
une question à vous poser c'est la
tradition de cette émission sous forme
de dessin on écoute on regarde les
sanctions sont elles la solution en est
rude monsieur le président vous êtes né
à l'ouest dans l'orne au pays du boiret
terre d'élevage et de mémoire puisque la
normandie fut le théâtre d'une des plus
grandes batailles de la seconde guerre
mondiale la question que je posais dans
deux temps n'avons nous pas commis une
grave erreur en suivant la politique
énergétique de l'allemagne et l'enfer
étant pavé de bonnes intentions par nos
sanctions ne risque-t-on pas debout
c'est la russie dans les bras de la
chine faisant naître à l'est un monstre
militaro industriel coté sur la question
européenne 70 ans après le traité de
rome on
continue à se demander régulièrement si
l'autre ne nous a pas dupe et donc apte
ont bien fait de suivre les allemands
sur la politique énergétique les
allemands aujourd'hui doivent se
demander s'ils ont bien fait d'accepter
de mettre en commun des dettes garantis
par le budget de l'union européenne moi
je crois pas que la question elle se
pose ainsi lorsque l'on forme marché
unique de 500 millions de citoyens avec
des institutions communes et j'ai au
contraire le sentiment que positif que
ces derniers temps ces dernières
semaines malheureusement le le sentiment
européen a progressé et l'idée j'allais
dire y compris d'une d'une défense
européenne qui était poussé par la
france qui paraissait totalement
anachronique à progresser quand quant à
la russie et la chine moi je considère
que aujourd'hui la priorité c'est
d'essayer de mettre un terme à cette
guerre qui est tout à fait insoutenable
je pense que les sanctions économiques
sont nécessaires pour mettre un terme à
cette guerre est naturellement il faut
poursuivre les efforts diplomatiques
c'est toute la difficulté d'ailleurs de
l'europe de vouloir mettre fin à une
guerre sans faire la guerre elle-même
françois-xavier l'offrant la une new
west france aujourd'hui alors là une de
ouest france avec une question est ce
qu'on ne va pas ce qu'on n'est pas en
train d'aller vers une crise du logement
majeur avec l'inflation des prix du
logement neuf c'est un vrai sujet un
vrai sujet est aussi la difficulté pour
les professionnels du bâtiment de se
faire livrer du matériel aujourd'hui on
est on est on est vraiment dans une
période de très forte tension qui
inquiète beaucoup notamment évidemment
sur les sur les territoires vous
retournez dans votre région
régulièrement très régulièrement et
comme le disait le dessinateur chenu je
suis un grand amateur des paysages du
bocage et aussi de ses productions le
poiré notamment auquel il a fait
référence cet apport le poiré vous
pouvoir et du temps fontaine puisque
vous êtes de domfront merci françois
xavier le franc rédacteur en chef 2 ou
est france le journal aussi sans carte
de presse c'est ça 620 passionné les
français merci infiniment il ressent un
instant denis carot le directeur des
rédactions du groupe nice matin sur ce
plateau
[Musique]
bonjour denis carot vous êtes le
directeur des rédactions du groupe nice
matin c'est à dire var matin également
merci d'être avec nous dans un instant
nous allons interviewé ensemble donc
notre invité ce matin thierry beaudet le
président du conseil économique social
et environnemental mais pour l'instant
nous partons pour la martinique fort de
france et ses scieries de boutiers le
directeur éditorial de ce partenaire de
cette mission qui a une question à vous
poser thierry baudet on écoute bonjour
thierry beaudet le conseil économique et
social s'est à plusieurs reprises
pencher sur la question de la vie chère
aux antilles en guyane et dans les
outre-mer en général
en en cherchant les racines
l'éloignement le transport les systèmes
de distribution monopolistique etc etc
où en est on
votre institution at elle pu avancer sur
des sur des pistes de modification en
sachant que cette question de la vie
chère rejoins totalement la question de
du pouvoir d'achat et de la hausse des
prix en métropole voilà le cee et les
départements et territoires d'outre-mer
on a une délégation aux outre mer c'est
à dire qu'on traite ont fait un focus
spécifique sur la question des outre-mer
dans de travaux et la question posée est
aujourd'hui très importante on sait
combien les outre-mer sont dépendante
des importations notamment pour les
produits alimentaires de première
nécessité et le renchérissement du fret
du carburant est un sujet majeur qui
inquiète beaucoup parce que là il ya à
nouveau un risque de renchérissement
encore une fois des matières premières
et on sait que la situation est
socialement déjà explosive et on sait
que les outre-mer notamment avec les
zones maritimes territoriales sont un
grand atout pour la france naturellement
la section qui pose des questions de
relocalisation d'un certain nombre
d'activités dans les outre mer notamment
denis carot dans ses yeux il y a eu la
fin environnementale effectivement
bonjour thierry baudet en 2008 le
conseil économique et social est devenu
conseiller économique et social
environnemental alors pourquoi ce en
plus et quels sont vos prérogatives sur
ce sujet écoutez le le e a vraiment
apporté une assise plus forte au conseil
est la première conséquence c'est que la
dimension environnementale depuis
maintenant plus de dix ans est
systématiquement présente dans tous nos
travaux quand on parle
agriculture naturellement on parle de la
fonction nourricière de l'agriculture
met aussitôt en ajoute une dimension
environnementale notamment en quoi et
comment l'agriculture française peut
contribuer à capter et à stocker le
carbone canton par l'industrie
relocalisation d'activités industrielles
on pense simultanément verdissement de
l'industrie quand on pense aménagement
du territoire et notamment logement on
l'évoqué tout à l'heure avec la une
d'ouest france on pense d'abord aux
passoires thermiques et au passoires
énergétiques
c'est vraiment au coeur au coeur de nos
préoccupations
et puis on a été sollicité sur toutes
les grandes politiques publiques
environnement l'oréal j'ai justement
voulez vous l'évoquez tout à l'heure
c'est le c'est ce qui a mis en place la
convention citoyenne pour pour le climat
c'était après la crise des gilets jaunes
quels enseignements vous tiré de cette
de cette expérience
je pense que
d'abord ça a permis de vérifier la
validité de ce type d'opération c'est à
dire que le rail vas-y tire tirage au
citoyen 50 citoyens tirés au sort
dès lors qu'on organise un débat entre
égaux sur la base d' arguments
raisonnés peuvent appréhender des sujets
dont on dit qu'ils sont d'une grande
complexité et peuvent formuler des
propositions encore une fois qu'ils
soient censés et raisonnée ce que c'est
le premier élément le deuxième élément
ils se sont incroyablement
engagé sur ces 150
citoyens 13 parmi eux en suivant on
était candidat pour la première fois à
des élections sur un large spectre
politique comment pourrait-on considérer
que la démocratie dans des cellules
renouveau et qu'ils ont été élus jeu gb
je peux pas plus de dire j'ai pas screen
et j'ai passé jacques et quentin j'ai
pas ce cri oui mais ce qui compte c'est
qu'ils se sont intéressés à la vie
publique et qu'ils se sont engagés ça
montre qu'il ya une volonté d'engagement
de nos citoyens mais elle aura été
concluants pour autant sur les 149
propositions qui ont été formulées la
critique est revenu de la part des
membres de cette convention c'est que
très peu ont été ont été reprises dans
le fond est ce que ça n'a pas été un
prétexte cette convention c'était une
première à l'échelle de notre de notre
pays moi j'observe quand je rencontre
mes homologues européens et africains
notamment que tous nous interroge sur
cette convention citoyenne le climat
d'une certaine manière est là elle a
marqué les esprits elle a fait référence
est en effet est en effet à la fin il ya
pu avoir un sentiment d'inachevé ou de
frustration ça montre qu'il faut tirer
les enseignements de cette première
conférence il doit y en avoir d'autres
et notamment il faut dès le début est
clair sur le débouché et peut-être sans
doute le président de la république
s'est-il monter eux un peu imprudent en
indiquant qu'il reprendrait les
propositions sans vie dont il n'a pas
fait je pense que si lui n'en reste
qu'un jour je pense que si dans le
contrat de départ on avait dit vos
propositions seront transmises sans
filtre au parlement qui doit avoir le
dernier mot là d'une certaine manière le
contrat aurait été plus claire et il y
aurait probablement eu moins
d'insatisfaction à la fin vous avez des
contacts avec le président de la
république bat ans j'ai eu l'occasion
d'aider d'échanger avec lui notamment
après mais régulier les
constitutionnalistes et les contacts
entre le président du conseil économique
et social et environnemental et le
président de république ou c'est pas
institutionnaliser ce qui est beaucoup
plus institutionnels sont les relations
régulières avec le premier ministre et
son gouvernement duncan le cdh vient de
rendre un avis sur l'acceptent
l'acceptabilité des mesures liées à la
transition énergétique
est ce que les français sont prêts à
bouger sur ce sujet
ce qu'on s'est dit nous c'est qu'il
fallait un programme national national
d'aménagement du territoire pour les
infrastructures énergétiques tant qu'on
passera pas par cette phase là et chaque
fois qu'on prendra le sujet j'allais
dire localement on refera l'ensemble du
débat
sur wii on refera autant de fois le
débat qu'il y aura deux projets
d'infrastructure donc nous on avis il
faut commencer par un programme national
d'aménagement du territoire pour ses
infrastructures 2 on dit il faut
développer la concertation territoriale
et 3 et 3 crois que c'est assez novateur
on dit il faut intéresser les
territoires d'implantation les
territoires d'implantation 6 en milieu
rural qu'on va implanter les éoliennes
le photovoltaïque et c'est d'abord et
c'est d'abord pour fournir en énergie
les grandes métropoles mais on sait
qu'en milieu rural par exemple il ya des
des services publics qui ont déserté ya
des déserts médicaux et bien dans les
contreparties et on nous on pense qu'il
faut des contreparties qu'il faudrait
des nouveaux contrats de solidarité
entre territoires et il faut que les
territoires ruraux et un intérêt
à à l'installation de ces six de ces
énergies nouvelles renouvelables ni
qu'on avait parlé de l'éolien le débat
est très vif sur le sujet vous
préconisez en tout cas l'avis préconise
la nomination d'un médiateur à quoi
servirait-il
je les dis il faut faire deux il faut
faire le véritablement de 2,2 de la
concertation de la concertation
territoriale mais encore une fois une
vraie concertation c'est à dire qui il
s'agit de créer de l'assise est et non
pas de la verticalité il a trop souvent
des consultations qui vise à aligner
finalement sur des décisions qui ont
déjà été prises et ça ça fonctionne pas
une médiation c'est pour créer de 2,2 de
l'assise sur laquelle on va pouvoir
développer des politiques publiques il
en échéance dans quelques jours il ya
quelques jours le cea
auditionner les candidats à la
présidentielle est ce que vous
considérez que la dimension
environnementale a été suffisamment
prises en compte dans leur programme
si vous faites référence aux auditions
cel portait sur la question démocratique
donc au cee ils ne se sont pas fortement
exprimée sur cette question puisque ce
n'était pas la question formulée
néanmoins je dois dire que dans nos
travaux depuis au fil de travaux on
alerte sur le fait que la france ne se
situe pas sur les trajectoires prévu de
réduction de nos émissions nationales
notre empreinte carbone nous sommes où
nous sommes préoccupés et nous pensons
que ce sujet doit être pris avec
davantage on le voit ce sujet il est
quasiment absent de la campagne c'est ce
que je vous dis il doit être pris avec
davantage de rigueur et la force et la
force du du cee nous disons qu'il faut
penser d'un même mouvement les grandes
transitions on doit il faut penser
j'allais dire un développement
économique qui pour assurer notre
prospérité commune qu'ils soient plus
durable il faut penser la transition
environnementale et il faut penser la
question sociale en même temps la
question sociale ne peut pas être un
sous-produit la transition environnement
pour compléter la question de denis
carot est ce que vous les avez trouvés
ces candidats jettent dire de bonne
facture est ce que vous avez trouvé que
le niveau de réponse face donc à votre
assemblée était bon et est à la hauteur
des enjeux du pays on les a interrogés
sur la question je parle globalement 1
on les a interrogés sur la question
démocratique tous ont fait le constat
d'une vraie fatigue démocratique rnd
avait trouvé qu'ils nous ont apportés en
fonction évidemment du spectre politique
dans laquelle ils appartiennent des
réponses
qu'elle a été la perception de cette
audition nous avons le
sentiment que le wiki qu'ils ont qu'ils
ont apporté des réponses certains
souhaitant modifier les institutions
d'autres voulant renforcer
la démocratie
participatif donc c'est un sujet sur
lequel ils avaient réfléchi et sur la
question environnementale parce qu'on
l'a évoqué rapidement on voit les
différences de trajectoire entre les
seins qui pensent qu'il faut modifier le
comportement d'autres qui pensent que
c'est le tout technologique qui réglera
la question environnementale est
naturellement tous les scénarii médian
la une de nice matin denis carot
l'inquiétante série noire on revient sur
la multiplication des cas d'intoxication
alimentaire avec notamment le témoignage
du père d'une fillette de deux ans qui a
été intoxiqués après avoir mangé des
chocolats kinder donc une nouvelle
alerte sanitaire en fait merci denis
carot directeur des rédactions du groupe
nice matin dans un instant armelle le
goff directrice de la rédaction de 20
minutes notre partenaire et sur ce
plateau merci dany chaos
[Musique]
bonjour armelle le goff merci d'être
avec nous dans un instant nous
continuons cette interview de du
président du conseil économique social
et environnemental thierry baudet mais
tout de suite nous partons pour la
nièvre nous partout pour nevers où jean
mathias jolie du groupe centre france la
montagne à une question à vous poser
thierry baudet une question du journal
du centre notre partenaire pour cette
émission sur l'abstention vous en
parlais tout à l'heure on écoute bonjour
monsieur vous dès le premier tour pour
être marqué dimanche par une abstention
importante selon les instituts de
sondages peut-être même une abstention
record pour une élection présidentielle
ma question est la suivante que
préconisez vous face à cette situation
comment faire pour que les citoyens les
associations la société civile se
sentent davantage concernés par la vie
publique la vie politique et quel levier
démocratique pourrait être activée pour
impliquer davantage les citoyens dans la
la vie publique pas seulement au moment
des élections d'ailleurs mais tout au
long de l'année c'est tout au long de
l'année à la fin la question j'en ai dix
ans j'en ai dit un mot si le
l'abstention s'établit à un niveau élevé
la candidate ou le candidat élu sera
certes légitime mais n'aura pas refait
le plein de carburant démocratique pour
pouvoir traverser tout son mandat a
fortiori dans un monde changeant donc
qui elle ou il aura besoin en permanence
de s'assurer de la solidité de son lien
à la société
elle ou il aura besoin en permanence de
se re légitimer et je pense que il aura
besoin d'un parlement qui joue
pleinement son rôle un parlement plus
fort et il aura besoin d'associer les
citoyens la participation citoyenne les
citoyens et la société la participation
citoyenne la participation des corps
intermédiaires tout ça et est très
important pour encore une fois donner de
la légitimité à l'action politique à
rennes le goff oui et peut-être aussi
avoir une place plus importante pour le
cee qui travaille aussi avec des ceser
est-ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer
l'articulation de ces travaux en région
et sur les territoires c'est vrai qu'il
région bien sûr et la revoilà alors il
n'y a pas de lien organique entre le cee
les césar les césar sont attachés aux
conseils régionaux ce sont des
organisations consultatives qui
travaille pour et avec les conseils
régionaux mais ce qui est sûr c'est que
nous nous sommes très attachés à la
dimension territoriale de nos
préconisations frein exemple on vient de
rendre un avis sur un service public de
la petite enfance on a par exemple
considérer que cette qu'on s'a ça devait
une compétence communale alors justement
sur ce sujet sur cet avis que vous avez
rendu sur le service public de la petite
enfance vous voulez que l'organisation
d'accueil reviennent aux communes et aux
intercommunalités re communalité qui ont
déjà beaucoup de responsabilités qui
disent qu'elles en ont trop est ce que
ce ne serait pas trop de leur donner
justement cette gestion de la petite
enfance écoutez on a considéré que sur
on considère que sur beaucoup de sujets
il faut faire le pari des territoires
est le pari des acteurs l'intelligence
d'un territoire et l'intelligence des
acteurs et après des consultations
naturellement il nous est apparu que
c'était que c'était le bon échelon pour
organiser ce service public de la petite
enfance mais comment on fait pour faire
sa ba on auditionne j'allais dire des
acteurs des territoires les césar on le
voit sur les images d'ailleurs à la
maison ça se massent les ceser peuvent
participer à nos travaux on rencontre
des associations d'élus c'est le hasard
des calendriers hier j'ai rencontré
carole delga la présidente de
l'association des régions de france et
est le président de sita ni voilà et le
président de l'association des maires
ruraux donc on travaille beaucoup
beaucoup avec avec les élus cette
question là est très important vous
pensez que la france reste un état trop
centralisée aujourd'hui moi je pense que
les politiques publiques elle touche les
gens et donc on a besoin de demander
l'avis des personnes avant-hier au cee
on s'est livré à un exercice
d'évaluation des politiques de cohésion
européenne comment on a procédé on a
travaillé avec les ceser les césar sont
venus avec des porteurs de projets
locaux qui sont venus échanger avec des
acteurs de la commission européenne pour
dire ce qui avait fonctionné ce qui
n'avait pas fonctionné pourquoi voilà il
faut être concret il faut ancrer dans le
terrain quand j'en espère une prise
comme la crise des gilet jaune vous en
tant que membre du cae président du 6e
vous dites quoi
on est ce que vous aviez des gilet jaune
au cee coûté je ne sais pas il ne
portait pas le il ne portait pas le
chasuble sitel vous voyez bien si
l'ascendance si telle est la tendance je
glisse t je ne pense pas que quelqu'un
qu'elle existait moi j'en conclus que
dans une société où on a besoin de
celles et ceux qui structure la société
française de celles et ceux qui agissent
au quotidien et on a besoin des corps
intermédiaires peut-être c'est une leçon
est qu'il faut savoir davantage
dialoguer et écouter celles et ceux qui
agissent dans les territoires au plus
près des français je reviens sur la
question démocratique qui vous intéresse
au premier chef on a un baromètre
ouest-france 20 minutes et les journaux
loi sur l'intérêt à m lisa sion des
jeunes pour l'élection présidentielle
58% des jeunes selon notre baromètre ont
l'intention de voter ce dimanche c'est
mieux parce qu on était à dix points de
moins il ya quelques semaines mais c'est
encore trop peu comment est-ce qu'on
peut réconcilier la jeunesse et la
politique
en les faisant rentrer massivement cec
ça voilà alors votre réponse écoutez il
siège de ce2 et ils sont très
contributif au cse d'abord moi je me
méfie du terme la jeunesse je pense
qu'il ya des jeunes et bien sûr et et
danser jeunesse il ya des jeunesses qui
sont très engagés qui se mobilise on
voit les marches pour le climat on voit
la mobilisation sur par exemple les
questions d'égalité femmes hommes et
puis et puis il ya des genêts ceux ci
qui se sont repliés qui se sont mis en
retrait donc moi je crois qu'il faut
faire de la mort il faut que l'élection
soit utile c'est
l'utilité qui va mobiliser et puis il
faut refaire de la pédagogie du duduk du
système le bus du système démocratique
ça ne va pas de soi et on se rend compte
que dans beaucoup de deux pays il ya de
plus en plus de nos concitoyens dans de
nombreux pays qui considèrent que la
démocratie est une belle idée mais que
finalement elle fonctionne pas si bien
que ça et certains sont tentés allé dire
au nom de l'efficacité par des systèmes
qui serait moins démocratiques alors ils
sont davantage associer les citoyens
c'est une dernière question pour savoir
qu'il est président du cio vingt minutes
s'intéresse au sujet des crypto de la
blocs shane des mft qui intéressent
particulièrement la jeunesse qui
pourrait modifier
l'économie des années qui viennent est
ce que c'est un sujet par exemple qui
est dans votre champ d'intérêt au cee
alors ça pour être dans notre champ
d'intérêt au moment où je vous parle on
n'a pas travaillé sur ces sujets là mais
on travaille beaucoup par exemple sur la
nouvelle économie le digital le
numérique ces relations pour y est c'est
un vrai sujet dont on pourrait s'emparer
on ne l'a pas encore fait ben ça tombe
bien vous allez lire la prochaine
édition digitale du magazine 20 minutes
qui concerne le bloc shane leur blog
shane exactement 20 min c'est un
magazine qu'on fera paraître fin mai sur
ces sujets et puis là vous avez la une
du journal les jeunes ont la charte et
aux morts la jeunesse qui se mobilisent
visiblement un peu plus pour cette
élection mais pas suffisamment merci
beaucoup à mal le goff directrice de la
rédaction de 20 minutes notre partenaire
dong joint-venture comme on dit entre
ouest france et la voix du nord merci
infiniment dans un instant des maîtres
korkmaz de tv5 monde sur ce plateau avec
nous pour les questions internationales
[Musique]
bonjour des maîtres korkmaz merci d'être
avec nous alors je vous connaissez
thierry baudet vous l'avez vu juste
avant cette émission voilà on peut pas
l'imaginer mais en fait le cee émergent
à l'international en tout cas vous étiez
la semaine dernière en côte d'ivoire et
vous avez notamment été reçu par le
président alassane ouattara il a été
question de l'ukraine qu'est ce qu'il
vous a dit à propos de ce conflit voilà
le le le président
ouattara et est très inquiet sur
la question des céréales du du blé
notamment
et ils appellent
l'europe et la france a à réorienter sa
production notamment vers la côte vers
la côte d'ivoire vers vers la zone uemoa
et il suffit de regarder une carte pour
voir qu'il ya un sujet majeur pour la
france et pour l'europe naturellement on
n'a pas entendu les dirigeants africains
sur ce conflit sur la russie par exemple
ils prennent pas beaucoup position ils
sont très en retrait ce que vous
comprenez cette attitude ou comment vous
comprenez cette attitude je pense que
vous faites notamment
référence au président du sénégal macky
sall macky sall est aujourd'hui
président de l'union africaine et et
naturellement sur l'union africaine je
pense notamment dans l'afrique du sud
dans l'afrique de l'est
on n'a pas tout à fait les mêmes
positions probablement que dans la zone
uemoa
en afrique de l'ouest et je pense que
c'est sa présidence de l'union africaine
qui explique sa relative discrétion
alors justement thierry baudet vous êtes
attachés aux questions de citoyenneté le
directeur de l'information de télé 78 la
chaîne des yvelines partenaires et
coproductrice de cette émission à une
question à vous poser on écoute
bonjour notre démocratie malade elle est
fragile nous sommes peut-être arriver au
bout du cycle de la démocratie
représentative pourtant qu'une a soigné
des spécialistes comme dominique
rousseau propose une démocratie en
continu ne serait ce pas la plus belle
réforme de votre conseil que de devenir
cette nouvelle assemblée des citoyens et
c'est valable pour les ce1 externe aussi
alors
puisqu'il a été fait référence à
dominique rousseau j'aime beaucoup lui
emprunter une formule dominique rousseau
quand il évoque la la démocratie
représentative
il dit finalement demain dimanche pardon
quand les français vont aller donner
leur voix d'une certaine manière après
c'est comme s'ils étaient muets ils ont
donné leur voix ils sont mués en réalité
les français même après l'élection ils
veulent continuer à donner de la voix et
et je pense que c'est ça le
je pense que c'est ça le sujet il faut
encore une fois faire démocratie
entre deux élections il faut associer
les corps intermédiaires associés
associer les citoyens et je les dis
renforcer le rôle renforcé le rôle du
parlement thierry beaudet selon un
récent sondage du parlement européen
seuls 52% des français estiment qu'il
est important d'appartenir à l'union
européenne
pourtant les allemands sont plutôt
d'accord à 70% comment vous interpréter
cet écart est ce que l'europe a échoué à
entrer dans le coeur des français d'une
certaine manière écoutez moi j'ai le
sentiment on
verra les enquêtes d'opinion dans
quelques semaines et dans quelques mois
on s'en serait bien passé mais j'ai
quand même le sentiment que ces
dernières semaines avec avec la guerre
en ukraine le sentiment européen a
fortement progressé
le sentiment d'appartenance à une
communauté de destin à des valeurs
communes a progressé et on a même
j'allais dire progresser sur le fait
qu'il fallait doter l'europe des
instruments de sa puissance donc je
crois vraiment que les choses ont évolué
de ce point de vue là très positivement
comment l'union européenne pourrait
contribuer à ce que les citoyens les
jeunes citoyens européens se sentent
davantage concernés par par cette europe
là encore l'europe parfois paraître un
peu lointaine vous savez je fais un
parallèle avec ce qui existe en france
le sait ce que je préside peut être
saisie par les citoyens par voie de
pétition il existe une initiative
citoyenne européenne qui est une sorte
de super droit de pétition à l'échelle
de l'union qui avait été instauré en
2009 s'est jugée trop complexe par les
citoyens ça ne fonctionne pas ça n'a
jamais vraiment trouvé sa place je pense
par exemple que des dispositifs de cette
nature doivent être
simplifier tient au mode et vous parlez
beaucoup de consultation des citoyens en
france en europe est ce que vous ne
pensez pas qu'il est aussi important que
ces institutions aussi soit capable de
rendre des comptes et que l'art de la
démocratie ça n'est pas simplement la
consultation mais aussi de rendre des
comptes pour que les citoyens soient
soient conscients de ceux de
l'efficacité éventuelle desserte de
certaines actions publiques alors vous
avez raison il ne faut pas que la la la
participation citoyenne la délibération
citoyenne il faut pas que ce soit un
gadget un tour de passe-passe une
argutie il faut que le contrat soit
clair sur le débouché il faut que le
contrat soit très clair et il faut que
celles et ceux à qui les travaux des
citoyens seront transmis et l'obligation
de rendre des comptes la redevabilité la
reddition des comptes et et centrale et
pour ce faire je crois qu'il faut
vraiment pour qu'on ait une chance que
ça fonctionne il cette participation
citoyenne il faut l'accrocher à la
république et c'est pour ça que je pense
que le cee est le lieu idéal pour le
faire et en effet pour répondre un peu
plus directement à la question
précédente c'est un enjeu majeur at risk
ardue dudu du cee le cee est aujourd'hui
l'assemblée de la société civile
organisée demain on veut en faire le
l'assemblée de la société ci encore de
contrôle de l'action publique par
exemple ça c'est quelque chose que vous
réprouvé ou est-ce que vous regrettez
parce que au fond
l'intérêt que l'on peut porter que la
jeunesse ou que la populace qu'une
population peut porter à la politique à
la démocratie c'est aussi de savoir
s'il y a des comptes qui sont rendus
s'il y a des mesures qui sont prises
efficace pas efficace si ce qu'on manque
de contrôle
c'est la perception par exemple que nous
avons c'est eux lorsque nous remettons
des avis au gouvernement quand il nous
les a demandé nous avons parfois jugé
que le retour qui nous en étaient faits
n'étaient pas suffisamment alors
justement syrie on a progressé mais la
question vous comme reddition des
comptes et avec laquelle premier
ministre puisque vous l'avez expliqué
c'est l'interlocuteur du conseil
économique social et environnemental
avec quel premier ministre avez vous le
mieux travailler donnez moi non non mais
écoutez moi j'ai été élu ça fait tout
juste une année j'ai connu mes
deux premiers deux premiers ministres
edouard philippe et jean castex et je je
je considère que nous avons noué des
relations de travail de qualité avec les
deux premiers ministres et leurs deux
gouvernements une question ils ont leurs
questions ils sont légitimes à nous les
poser et nous avons nos réponses combien
cc rémunérer un conseiller au conseil
économique social et environnemental
3000 euros par mois de l'ordre de 3000
euros avec des avantages vous savez que
les français sont très sensibles à ça il
ya des avantages liés à cette à cette
fonction il ya une caisse de retraite il
n'y a pas d'autres avantages liés à
cette fonction si ce n'est que
naturellement on a dit que les les
conseillers étaient pour beaucoup en
province quand ils viennent à paris lors
de leur transport leur hébergement
leurs frais de restauration sont
naturellement rembourse 40 millions
d'euros de budget de voyage seulement en
augmentation ou fait des efforts de
bonne gestion pour diminuer cette
dotation non il ya une stabilité il ya
une stabilité du budget alors que nous
avons été réformé en 2021 nous avons une
nouvelle réforme à mettre en oeuvre nous
avons de nouvelles missions la
participation citoyenne le lien avec les
territoires et nous le faisons à budget
constant ce qui montre que nous avons su
faire des efforts d'optimisation